now that's a sunburn President Biden
back from vacation in St Croy and
apparently he forgot to pack his
sunscreen the president's sporting a red
face critics say that it's not
surprising considering he spent 37% of
2023 enjoying vacation destinations and
now that Biden is back home out of the
sunshine the president is set to Pivot
into dark Brandon mode yes we found out
his team is ramping up as 2024 campaign
by of course focusing on Trump upcoming
events designed to symbolize the fight
for democ Ry and of course the former
president Jesse are you concerned about
the president not using enough SPF well
I blame his dermatologist Dr Jill I
believe she's the
dermatologist he looks like George
Hamilton you have to be able to take
care of yourself if you're going to take
care of the country and the man just had
skin cancer a year ago and then goes out
and gets totally roasted in the sun it's
Reckless I'm not going to make a sunburn
a scandal but this is impeachment
material I
agree the fact that he skipped the 9/11
ceremony and is going to show up for the
January 6 ceremony is a disgrace at this
point why don't we just make January 6 a
Federal holiday like we did with juneth
it's my Christmas it is your Christmas
merry January it's a great Orthodox
going to be some it's a Greek Orthodox
and you can't say you're running to save
democracy but you're not allowed to vote
for your other guy you're not allowed to
do that exactly so the what do you think
I mean that we found out also that his
team is just waiting to figure out when
to go full Hitler you know I mean this
unir thing Liz Warren is really pissed
because only she can pass herself off as
a
and finally though I will say
this Joe finally got burned by a
different
son but but according to the Hitler
isation this is what overshadows this
whole thing is the orchestrated effort
to remove their Chief rival from the
ballot and also to demonize and also to
use lawfare in order to basically create
an unfair election they are doing
everything possible but running a
candidate have you noticed that there's
nothing else that they're doing they're
not even running a reelection campaign
all they're doing is Trump Trump trump
Trump trump and here's the sad part if
Trump didn't run in 2016 none of these
efforts to destroy his business would
ever exist so what does it tell America
it's cause and effect if a political
Outsider runs for president we will
destroy you and this is why Dana I'm not
running in 2028 I can't have the media
poking into my mail order leather goods
company right I mean because that's
actually there's some good products
there there are there are and they do
fit you what's the website again it's uh
uh um gimp.org okay okay well everybody
check everybody check that out judge
what do you make of the either the
campaign strategy or the idea that he's
going to go dark brand
well look he doesn't have a choice he's
got nothing to offer the public is
rejecting him 71% we said I think I said
this yesterday in the swing States think
he's too old to run 70% of America at
least thinks we're going the wrong
direction he's lost 25 points with the
blacks he's behind with the Hispanics
he's behind with the Youth of this
country he's got nothing else so what is
he going to do he's going to go out
there and talk about how it is you know
Donald Trump is a threat to democracy
while he makes sure that Donald Trump
isn't on the ballot I mean the whole
thing is backwards and you know he can
save democracy all he wants but he's
going to do January 6th I just V
Envision him with those those Marines
behind him with guns and that blood red
background then I think he's going to
Charlottesville um he's got nothing else
to offer Trump is beating him and he's
beating him for good reason and that's
all I have to say Okay U Jessica I mean
it is the case that when you if you're
an incumbent you want to make the
election a choice yeah between two
people and not a referendum on your
record especially if the record is
getting the kind of reviews that Biden's
is his record is actually getting good
reviews it is being ignored there were
people all over our own Airwaves from
The Wall Street Journal to people from
the Biden campaign talking about the E
economic record talking about what bomic
has done for the average person The Wall
Street Journal ran editorials ran
reported pieces about all the optimism
heading into it the stock market is
exploding the jobless race down
inflation is easing gas prices we never
talked about remember when you guys told
me uh drill baby drill he won't drill
we're now producing more oil than any
other country in history 13.3 million
bar but they don't want to claim that as
an accomplishment yeah no they do listen
to Jared Bernstein he showed up he was
on Fox over the weekend go why you jar
berstein what a chief economic adviser
that's why doesn't the president say
anything
show what he had nothing on his schedule
but he just got back from two weeks in
the Caribbean this idea that Trump is
blowing him out of the water is just not
supported by the data you love the real
CLE politics average it's within the no
it's within the margin of error look at
the last three or four polls Trump's up
two in one then it's tied in the other
then bidens up one and the other if you
believe that Trump will win by 20 points
of the black vote I have many many
bridges to sell you or the youth vote
the guy had vanilla ice at his New
Year's Eve party and you think he's
winning dare you Jessica you I have
heard a lot from you over the years but
that will not stand Ice Ice Baby you're
losing the youth vote yeah but do you
know what you do this data and it's
always out of context yes it is it's out
of cont we're coming off a pant so it's
like hey we're getting jobs back it's
like yes because everything went down
like
that stop collaborate and
listen the jobs are back and then to go
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else